oh heavens no not the green one
pull anyone but the green one the wire
dilemma is something that we see in many
movies which wire to cut it adds a lot
of tension to the movie hi gq i'm paul
wurze i'm an explosives expert if you
want it to go boom i'm your man and this
is the breakdown
[Music]
speed bypass the remote current with the
battery can you find the tripwire for
the remote i don't know i got a few
choices here
black and red
and green the villain who planted this
bomb was an x-bomb squad expert howard
payne atlanta pd bomb squad retired in
sun valley in 1989 when a small charge
left him with fingers numbering nine
that's our scumbag
and this device is made so it's going to
be very very difficult to disarm and
that's important because someone like
myself
could potentially be your worst
nightmare basically i can't go into any
more detail otherwise it's building a
bomb 101 because otherwise all these
kids are listening and they're going oh
yeah i can do that
[Laughter]
i want you to clip on the battery and
then run it to the lead wire
i can't bypass it'll fire
it's a collapsible circuit technically
you could have a dual circuit taking
down one circuit would activate a backup
circuit and cause it to blow up they now
know their chances of diffusing get slim
so they have to take a different
approach entirely
i want you to get out of there and sit
tight we're gonna go after the source
matt get me out of here
that was
right cool it's a sophisticated device
and it's in a terrible environment to
work on it's underneath a bus that's
traveling at 50 mile an hour that's
really really difficult working with
this device okay in a lab or somewhere
that's easy access is one thing under
there
no way at all and if you cut the power
from it it's got redundancy and a
relay's gonna close and it's gonna go
boom the abyss
what we're looking at on the left hand
side is the detonating device as soon as
he's taken that device out now he's
flooded the bomb with sea water which is
salty and conductive so it's going to
stop it working in a heartbeat have you
ever dropped cell phone over the side of
your boat once you've been at the
seaside
don't work anymore in this clip we have
stripe wires and there are different
colors but with that
glow stick
being green it confuses what the actual
colors are now there's some problems
with this and the first one is the way
electricity works is you have to have
two wires to make a circuit so that
really doesn't matter which wire he cuts
it will break the circuit
if you're ever in this situation i'd
recommend cutting both the wires at the
same time
mission impossible three lots of great
effects in this film
so one of the items on this movie is
spray-on explosive foam it actually
exists it was developed for clearing
minefields but the guy who was
developing it uh used on a minefield in
the falklands
and uh accidentally blew himself up and
i suspect what happened it was something
like a bouncing betty where you have
these little spikes sticking up and
while he was spraying the the foam on it
the foam pushed the spike over the
setting off the mine the way it works is
you spray on the foam you stick a
blasting cap in and fire it and this
foam itself has loads of little bubbles
of air or gas in it which actually helps
sensitize it
ethan get out of the truck
one of the things i noticed was the
drone that was used in the movie was
firing missiles it's more likely he's
going to be dropping guided bombs all of
the weight of the device okay can be the
frag and the
explosive plus of course you've got a
guidance package on it if we look
however at a missile most of it's going
to be
the actual rocket propelling it however
missiles can be fired very very quickly
and guided to their target as well
i like the guided missile impacting the
suv and causing a huge explosion but one
problem with it is tom cruise is blown
sideways now if that had been real he'd
have been blown
forwards not sideways he'd be blown
directly away from the explosion tom
cruise likes to do all his own stunts
but with that hit into the side of that
car
i'd have preferred to have a stuntman do
it for me
naked gun two and a half one of my
all-time favorite comedies
[Music]
let's get out of here one
[Music]
look did it
if you take the power away from
something it stops working
and you know when you when you're
defusing something if you can cut that
power uh source okay it's not gonna
function
[Music]
you've got a computer that runs on
clockwork and talks
at the same time 20 seconds to
detonation
this is a fantastic spoof of goldfinger
in goldfinger sean connery is looking at
the countdown not knowing what to touch
what to try and rip apart and all of a
sudden the expert appears over his
shoulder and turns the off switch
turn the off switch kills the power it's
as simple as that every electrically
initiated bomb needs a power source now
you usually use a battery but in this
case it's plugged into the wall socket
so
accidentally pulling out the plug
takes away the power and everything
stops and the bombs killed the
significance of a countdown timer is
that it gives you time to get away from
a bomb if you
flip the switch manually so having a
countdown timer is important because you
get this visual clue that it's actually
working in real life the guy who built
this device probably wouldn't put it
such front and center however for the
camera it's important to get that
good camera angle if you can't defuse
the bomb you may be able to relocate it
so let's look at an example of that
the dark knight rises what are you doing
i can get it out over the bay
set it to fly out over the water that
eject
no autopilot he knows he can't defuse
the bomb so his only option is to get it
as far away from the city as possible to
protect the city he needs to get several
miles away from it before it detonates
depending on the yield of the device and
that's the question it appears he didn't
have quite enough time to do that to get
it far enough away however the actual
nuclear explosion is way in the distance
almost over the horizon so that puts it
at probably seven miles plus the flash
is fairly realistic
okay but the after effects one still
would expect some significant movement
of air
there in the city it'd be noticeable
also a fairly big explosion a big boom
to go along with it the best film that
i've seen uh portraying a nuclear device
an explosion is in true lies and i think
they really got it spot on even to the
individual mirv warhead
and then the question comes would he
survive i think so landing in the water
that's going to give him pretty good
protection as long as he jumped out as
soon as he got over the water the
explosion's about to go off and you're
within range let's talk about taking
cover
indiana jones and the kingdom of the
crystal skull do not remove goggles or
face burst until 10 seconds after first
light oh that can't be good at all
[Music]
in the united states we've had around
800 nuclear weapons tests between the
nevada test site and also white sands in
some of these tests especially early on
they put out cities and arrays of
buildings and things like that to
actually test to see what the effect of
a nuclear weapon was on these various
distances both close in and far away to
determine exactly
what effects that happen how far away
from that blast a nice little touch they
have on the film is that when you see
him open the door of the refrigerator
it's got a label on it that says lead
lined they used to use lead for all
sorts of things back then
refrigerators are extremely sturdy that
lead gives you quite a lot of protection
from a radiation burst some of the older
folks will remember having to get under
a desk at school in nuclear drills and
what happens in a nuclear explosion is
around 5 psi of pressure will absolutely
rip a house apart whereas humans if
you're really lucky can last up to
somewhere near 200 psi
except you're not going to be in very
good shape over 100 psi so it's not the
pressure of the explosion that's going
to get you if you're in a house it's
probably the house falling on you
the other thing about uh being inside
something that's substantial is that
the blast wave as it comes in is gonna
reflect off that and we have a thing
called the impedance mismatch equation
what happens is you get very little
transmitted from a low density material
like air to a higher density and then
with all those planes inside that until
you get to the inside the refrigerator
that's going to soak up a lot of that
blast energy it's almost like having
your own
mobile blast shelter the question is
would that explosion send that
refrigerator that far
and probably the answer is no indy took
quite a hit when that refrigerator
landed i don't know whether you could
survive that because that was pretty
hard landing
fortunately for him it broke the lock on
the refrigerator and that used to be in
a problem in the old days because kids
are getting refrigerators and get locked
in them so being in that refrigerator as
long as he's far enough away from the
blast he'd survive it but
the impact when it landed yeah
probably wouldn't survive that
well did he do the right thing taking
the refrigerator well maybe he should
have looked for the basement
so the footage is really very realistic
when you see those mannequins start to
melt okay that would be caused by the
intense light and heat specifically in
the infrared region of course light
travels very very quickly it's almost
instantaneously the speed of light now
if we count
how many seconds it is between that
flash of light to the shock wave hitting
the buildings and starting to rip them
apart we can estimate roughly how far
that explosion was from the town and we
do that by using approximately
1 000 feet per second of delay let's
count it shall we let's run it again and
count it
one thousand one thousand two thousand
three
thousand four
thousand five
thousand six okay
five seconds
it's about the right distance what i'd
expect to put a town out there a shock
wave is gonna go faster than the speed
of sound so that would put it in
somewhere around one mile
from where the actual nuclear weapon
detonated to the location of the town
the actual buildings coming apart looks
very accurate basically during the
explosion you get this huge shock wave
and air pushed in front of it and that
causes those buildings to lean in all
the old nuclear weapons test photographs
and cine film you can actually see those
buildings lean away from the explosion
and then when there's a vacuum and it
sucks all the air back in it really
rocks the buildings and trees the other
way and oftentimes sucks them off their
foundations
the hurt locker butcher shop two o'clock
dude has a phone why is eldridge running
make him put it down put down the phone
come on guys talk to me
drop the phone drop your phone the
significance of the cell phone is that
typically in iraq these bombs were
actually actuated by a second cell phone
incorporated into the device
[Music]
[Music]
son
the explosion goes off and the question
is does he get far enough away and is
this realistic in the movies it's very
very difficult to show a shock wave in
the air unless you actually do it now i
could have done this but
you know the health and safety people
would not been too happy about it the
question is does the shock wave get him
or is it frag from that explosion i
think he's far enough away from the
blast there to get away from the shock
wave i think he would have survived the
shock wave but if anything got him it
was most likely the frag from the device
and usually in these ieds in iraq they
used actual ordnance shells and things
like that and projectiles okay and then
prying them initiated those and that not
only gave blast but also gave a lot of
tiny metal particles flying through the
air up to about two kilometers a second
that's nearly as fast as most speeding
bullets it's a brilliant effect with the
actual blood starting to splatter on the
front of
his visor from inside the way i would
see it probably took some frag to the
head i think for the individual
character all these things are great
things to write into a movie give all
these little nuances to give the
audience an idea of of what it's
actually like now
in reality the kind of person
who's going to be an eod specialist is
going to be dogged at
reaching their
goal and achievement this is because eod
school
okay is very tough there's a lot of
perseverance a lot of ability to
remember things and just pure doggedness
to get through this sort of thing i
often get asked about explosions in
films the question always is was that
realistic to real life unfortunately the
answer is no explosions in real life
look very drab
on the whole in this explosion there's a
number of items that actually go off
debris being thrown everywhere into the
air and then afterwards there's a
fire ball that's set off a lot of extra
things can be put in in films in special
effects that really makes the
explosion look absolutely fabulous
the long kiss good night
ready yeah and
[ __ ] it
no way out
okay
that's a three-star
are you crazy
[Music]
my first impression was that grenade
laid there so long it must have been a
dirt
because it took way too long to go off
okay now the second thing is uh how far
that fireball went that was just
incredulous so the grenade we see there
in the picture is a
more modern type of grenade in the old
days they used to have pineapple
grenades that actually looked like a
pineapple with big chunky segments on
them the old pineapple grenades caused
chunks to fly out
and these chunks hit people and kill
them whereas the modern grenade is
designed to wound people rather than
kill them and they generally wire around
when the grenade the high explosive
charge goes off it rips that wire into
lots of little pieces and that shreds
everything pretty nasty devices when a
normal grenade goes off it's like a
white puff and there's frag going
everywhere and it's
it's pretty bad news there isn't a big
fireball like that and that's obviously
a special effect for the audience
however there are some grenades that do
actually catch on fire those are known
as phosphorus grenades and in fact some
of those were used in the falklands war
okay by the british troops to clear
trenches phosphorus burns and it's
pretty nasty okay so it's a crispy
critter times with that stuff the actual
color of the light would be different if
i want to talk about it technically this
one really looks like a fuel explosion
rather than a phosphorous burning if
that was a phosphorus grenade their
backs would be on fire before they got
out of the
window but of course going into the icy
cold water would probably extinguish it
the hurt locker
oh god
the type of bomb this is is a vbied
which is a vehicle born ied which is an
improvised explosive device and
basically if we use a vehicle we can
take a lot of explosives somewhere
rather than just
something the weight of a backpack
okay let's pause here the key here is
the windshield wipers it's an arid
environment so you're not going to use
them except to maybe
clear a bit of dust off the windshield
that is one of the possible locations
you could attach an explosive device too
electrically there's obviously something
wrong with this ied because with those
windshield wipers going backwards and
forwards it should have gone off
what the hell
i don't know what the [ __ ] is doing
looks like he's checking the oil
now he has a good idea what's going on
and he opens the hood and he's looking
for wires the easiest place to connect
something to is to the battery for power
so he grabs halt of this wire that's
connected to the battery that shouldn't
be there and rips it out next he looks
for the arming switch for the bomb which
if you're going to be driving a vb ied
you're gonna have within reach of the
driver
he locates that and then he looks for
the relay that then sets the bomb off
and he actually rips that out to disable
it
we're done
it's not like you're dealing directly
with explosives you're dealing with
electrical wires so what he did was just
rip that out just like pulling out the
plug from a socket in the wall the term
ied improvised explosive device is what
we used to use in the old days for
anything we made in fact the fbi told me
not to use the word bomb because of the
connotations and being in research and
everything we built was an improvised
explosive device of course these days
it has a completely different
connotation worse than bomb
get out of here
we've seen cutting wires
ticking time bombs
and running away from the explosion this
one's got it all baby
lethal weapon three
relax right relax all right
that's way to rise we got nine minutes
and seven seconds left hey you know what
we can do you know what we could do what
we can drive this thing out of here hey
fine it's your turn to drive oh [ __ ] no
keys i got wired
i don't don't even see how i wear out
this stuff man you're right you're right
you're right you're right am i doing
this
looks like we're gonna have to do it the
old-fashioned way
now some people may say that that's a
mess of wires out there
but actually what we're looking at
they're green and yellow twisted and
they're the actual detonator wires to
each one of those detonators which is
poked into an individual block of
explosives now usually the detonators
have two wires coming out of them that
are separated but i guess you could
twist them together
okay to make it less of a mess with all
those detonators there the easy solution
to this one is to snip those wires one
by one
right where they go into the detonator
and then pull out that detonator plastic
cap and throw it away at that point you
can start disassembling all the rest of
the explosives okay if you can get to
every single one of those detonators in
fact probably looking at it you could
just pull them out if you couldn't reach
them properly and then snip them off are
you ready
i'm cutting away
see all done
so mel cuts the red wire and all of a
sudden that clock starts speeding up the
question is would that
happen in reality well
hey this is the movies what can i say
probably not but i think at a stretch if
you set it out to be that way as a kind
of booby trap
where if somebody started messing with
it it started counting down quicker and
then they knew heck we've got to get the
hell out of here because otherwise we're
toast that could be a plausible
explanation so mel snips the red wire
and then the clock starts speeding up
fantastically and the question is can
they get out of there in that a short
time period raj
yeah
grab that cat grab the cap
[Applause]
most people can't run a hundred yards in
10 seconds so they've only got a few
seconds there so they're going to be
pretty close when it goes off
but
there's really not that much explosive
there and yeah i think you could outrun
it
when that explosive went off in reality
it would make a different kind of effect
it would be a shock wave and blow dust
off everything can and kind of look
whitish
in color not a spectacular now this is
the movies and what you have there is
fireballs you've seen gasoline being
blown into the air and ignited to give
the effect
and that's quite different the building
itself was brought down by controlled
demolition using explosive charges and
that was separate and occurred a few
seconds after the main fireball in the
building they would have first had the
fireball at the front as they ran out
pull everybody back
to fire the main one
where there's fireballs and everything
coming out all the windows and debris
and everything and you'll notice about
five seconds after that the whole
building starts to drop
thanks for watching these clips with me
i hope you've learned a lot and until
next time